welcome to this video yeah this is
coverage for round five of my tournament
in but we say the open the variant
championships round five I was um at
three and a half points out of form
after had played this one hundred move
draw against the number one seed mikumi
on and three and a half out of four is
not a bad result but it was a kind of an
unlucky situation in terms of pairings
for me um and they turned out and
without going too much into details
about the Swiss system pairing a
technique that I was right at the the
cutoff between getting the strongest
possible opponent of the three and a
half point guys and the weakest and it
turned out that i got the weakest in
terms of rating which was very
disappointing because yeah you want to
get the best possible opposition for for
various reasons and yeah my opponent was
rated 2210 lilo and this was this was
the weakest out of the three and a half
point guys so let's see what happened in
this game and i can promise you that
it's a remarkable game um i went night
of 320 blade Knight f6 yeah in my
preparation I had noticed that he's not
a very theoretical play at all he mostly
played them off bid openings sometimes
Queens gambit setups but basically
leaving any theoretical known path early
so it didn't really make sense to
prepare much and this was pretty much um
yeah I mean I got a justification for
this approach very quickly as in this
position he played the move d5 and jung
and one needs to be perfectly honest
here this is just a mistake it's a it's
just a bad move the reason is that black
is exchanging a central pawn
porn for the sea pawn and this is not
the groom for defense this is a big
difference after the capture he took
deform there is no knight on c3 that
that black can capture in case of e for
hitting him and this is really a big big
issue if we look at something like g6
for example which is maybe the move that
is played most in this position when
people stumble into it after that why
play C 496 age 3 this is an important
didn't move that prevents any Bishop g4
pins yeah we want to prevent that the
problem is that now the night on b6 is
not in good shape and more importantly
almost if we look at the typical
situation here like here he cannot
easily use the C porn to attack the
center black often goes with something
like that but in this type of position
after move like Bishop c5 white is an
excellent shape yeah note that blank is
really passive if he play something like
c6e can resign after d6 no one possible
move and black is really passive both
nights are passive this is a position
that might look harmless at first but
give it to an engine it's on plus one
point something already which is pretty
accurate I think white has a big
advantage this is one of the better
lines though that that black can go for
um he played a move that that really
took me took me a bag a bit I mean the
whole this this already surprised me
because the 2200 player shouldn't play
this really but okay he went Knight f6
just returned to f6 it does one thing it
covers the e4 square so that I cannot go
inform yeah this is quite funny if you
look at this position um yeah it is some
it is similar to another position that i
will put on the bore now let's go all
the way back to move
one let's say we have this movie on the
total main line of the Queens gambit
accepted yeah remember this position I'm
going to jump now to the game position
you see just like magic there is a pawn
on c4 or not in our game position we
basically have a Queens gambit accepted
but he does not have a pawn on c4 so
this is very comfortable obviously for
wide as I'm not obliged to recapture on
c4 at any time there is no pawn so this
is just an excellent position for white
this also means that I don't need to
play moves like III I can just play 93
which which I did of course 93 preparing
e4 in the Queens gambit accepted when
there is a pawn on c4 now black can play
moves like a six or C 6 a-6 try to
support the beef the c-4 porn but there
is no pawn on c4 I just have a
well-known theoretical position that is
probably sometimes slightly better for
wide width without being a bond down
it's quite funny yeah he went six now
and that going for this is really a
classic advantage of an extra center
porn where there is no great counter
play he played Bishop e7 and he played
all this rather quickly um yeah and here
well white has the number of good setups
I went with Bishop d3 it looks like the
most natural move I guess and he played
the move c5 yeah what are possible Adam
continuation a thought of castling after
which I would have cancelled as well and
black already has some issues here if he
know those four count to play with c5
there is the movie 5 and it gets very
concrete soon something like that for
example is quite embarrassing
picking up a pawn in the process and
this is all due to the time losses and
giving white this central advantage he
played c5 and here I took a moment
because I thought that well okay it must
be good for white but how to exploit it
as best as possible um yeah and a first
thought okay why not take why not just
take after something like Bishop takes
castles I will play something like we
need to and e5 pushing the pawn to e5
and gaining lots of space this is in
fact very nice for wide but then I saw
that he might have this move intending
to answer d 5 with 95 well this is still
quite good for white if we look at
something like this white still has an
EDM it did not yeah it did not look
forceful enough to me so I was thinking
from some minutes like three or four
minutes not not too much and then I
pushed d5 which which seemed to be the
most aggressive to me um yeah this move
basically forces he takes d5 there is
there is no other reply so he takes d5
after that I had intended to push me
five this was my calculation and what
what I saw is that after a continuation
like for example an IG form I can play
age 30 I can take and I can exploit this
little tactic um yeah something like
this for example not the king with the
Queen something like this for example is
very dangerous for like I have this kind
of threat and if he takes on e5 this is
just fantastic provider with this direct
winning ideas black has a hard time to
survive this so so this is actually what
is forced after
I to my complete amazement after d5 he
just spent like I don't know maybe 15
seconds or something really quickly he
played the move a six and then I really
had a hard time not to look puzzled I
guess and I looked puzzled because a six
is just ignoring the the the main threat
of d5 I mean but it sort of the obvious
that i thought that okay he has to play
ed five anyway everyone else yeah right
to play and win d 6 hmm not exactly a
difficult tactical idea the point is
simply that after peace capture I'm
winning a piece by fork with e5 the same
happens of course after Queen takes e5
yeah so that that happened in the game
and after d6 he actually resigned
immediately so I had a win in nine moves
in round five of this tournament I was
totally a little bit in shock really
because we has to had just sat down at
the board and i had spent i get maybe 10
minutes or something and then I was it
was the piece thought I material Apple
I'm winning when did you resigned
actually yeah he he can continue
theoretically speaking with Bishop f8
yeah saving the piece but after
something like a five-night back and
Bishop g5 and blacks position is a ruin
of course I'm like three tempe up I have
those pawns on e5 and e6 it's terrible
and there are some very very concrete
lines already available if black plays
f6 for example just to show something
that's quite quite neat white can
already sacrifice here because of this
meeting idea Black has to take it and
then Queen d3 intending Queen g6 made
again only to be answered by this
this is just one possible line that is a
complete wind for white this attack is
yeah indefensible I cannot cannot
survive it yeah so in the actual game
after d6 he already resigned yeah it
totally weird game my opponent told me
afterwards that he was ill the day
before and was very very tired um yeah
you never know there are simply off days
that that happened but um I can really
can remember to ever have won a game
that quickly m-maybe yeah besides a
junior competitions when I was a I don't
know 14 years old or something quite
quite amazing yeah I hope you enjoyed
this this funny little video and maybe
you took something out of it and I think
what can be learned is that this type of
this type of opening is really am really
a bad for black by the way this is in
fact important if we think about a
position like that for example it is
very important that black is not playin
black does not play d5 here for the
green felt because there is no night
yeah yeah this is the same position that
could have happened in the game so it
happens in various moves orders another
move order that can lead to our game is
is this actually or even more common
this depends to the Queens gambit after
takes Queen takes Knight takes we get to
the game position it's by the way
important that 'if or is not as good as
after Knight f6 93 black has the counter
counter-strike a 5 which is not that bad
for him after takes takes and 94 black
in fact retains quite a quite an okay
position yeah it's important to
to avoid the e4 push but play Knight f3
first like we had in the game by a
transposition so this is may be a useful
opening tip for four players that play
d49 0 3 and 4 black players to avoid
this kind of trade of C against deep on
when you are not able to take on one c3
also note that white has not fianchetto
yet yeah I'm not committed to a
fianchetto there are situations where
black can play something like that for
example if we look at this here d 5 is a
viable line because after this the movie
form is not working dead well together
with g3 yeah here black retains a
playable position because I don't have
this this quick central dominance that I
have when when I can avoid g3 yeah I
hope you liked it too despite the game
not being really a really exciting and
yeah I got something out of it anyway
thanks for watching